[Music]
if you want to be an astronaut there are
three main things that are important
number one is simple just physical how
healthy is your body if you're gonna get
on a spaceship and leave Earth then it's
really difficult to go see a doctor or
to get to a hospital and so we need
people to be healthy part of that is
just a roll of the dice
what sort of makeup is your body you
know are you a person with a problem you
were born with
if so then maybe you're not going to be
an astronaut but that's you know maybe
you're not gonna be in the NBA maybe
you're not going to be whatever you are
who you are but given that you have a
certain body you can do a few things
obviously think about what you eat you
know you get a choice every time you put
something in your mouth so eat food
that's good for you and then exercise a
little bit you know take the stairs
don't drag your bag carry your bag walk
climb go for a run do something every
day a little bit physical it doesn't
take much but if you're careful about
what you eat and you do a couple of
physical things every day
then you're taking care of your body
that's step one number two is flying
spaceships is complicated its technical
and so if NASA is saying who we gonna
pick to be astronauts you want to pick
someone who has proven their ability to
learn complicated things you don't wanna
pick someone and what you don't know how
to learn this but if you pick someone
that has a doctorate in astrophysics and
also repairs their their 1955
Thunderbird in their own garage oh this
is a person that knows how to do
technical things they can learn complex
theory and they can get in there with
their hands and do stuff so the second
part is plan to always be a student
learning complicated things try and gain
qualifications that show that you can
learn complicated stuff so plan on an
advanced technical university degree
it's just like a ticket of entry the
third though we don't just want to hire
healthy students the third is can you
make good decisions and stick with them
especially when there's very high
consequence you know if if if something
really serious is happening
are you the person that can make the
right call make the right decision and
that's a skill learning to make
decisions is a skill you can get better
at it or you can always go home it's
above my pay grade
all right nah no I don't need to decide
that you can do that but then you are
not learning how to actually make a
decision and stick with your own
convictions so you can start small you
know just decide next month on the first
of the month I am going to do something
different with my life I'm going to wear
black every day for the whole month I'm
going to do 100 pushups every day for
the whole month I'm going to read 20
pages of I don't know Shakespeare every
month I'm going to learn five words of
Japanese every day this month make a
decision stick with it
by the end of the month you will have
changed who you are and if you choose
not to you will also have changed who
you are but in some random direction so
learning how to make decisions and stick
with them as the stakes get higher and
higher is also something we're really
looking for an astronaut selection so
those are the three main things take
care of your body get advanced complex
technical training preferably to at
least the master's degree in university
level and make decisions and stick with
them show that you're a person that that
can make the right call when the when
the chips are down and then hopefully
NASA will give you a call
[Music]